Kelsea talking of singing how did the
singing lead to Sideshow Bob in Oz oh
well Sam Simon who created the Simpsons
was one of the writers on cheers years
ago and as I do as is my won't I would
walk honor the said sometimes and I
would usually sing oh the good life kind
of been my best Tony Bennett kind of a
derivative and he called me one
afternoon said hey do you still sing
Cal's you know could you sing a Cole
Porter song every time I say goodbye of
course I could yeah I love that song
I said well we've got this character
who's never actually said anything on
the show he's cresting two clowns
sideshow we call him Sideshow Bob and we
want him to speak finally and we thought
you should do it can you sing this Cole
Porter so I said could certainly do that
and then I've read the script and it was
actually really funny and wonderful but
he was very cultured and I borrowed at
that time it seemed like the opportunity
I had logged away a voice years ago when
I worked for a man named Ellis Rabb
who had started a theatre company in New
York City had great success and when I
was working for him I was painting his
bathroom and you know hanging wallpaper
and stuff like that I wasn't really a
successful actor at the time but Alice
would regale me with stories when he'd
come home from work always and he would
say things like this he'd say oh kills
that baby should have been mine this guy
I'm gonna use him someday when I read
the script for such about I said this is
Ellis Raab and it went immediately into
Oh Bart
I just despise you
it's so stressful and I'm so tired and I
was so lonely here any day water up from
the bucket into the pump and then spray
the horse's penis with cold water bitter
and then the penis would just sort of go
back